so you seniors you graduates
you're at a pinnacle
of sorts
with any luck it won't be the last one
that's one metaphor pinnacle another how
about a crossroads
you're at a crossroads right you're
entering a new phase of your life you
can
you're someone different than you were
four years ago
and hopefully someone better
likely someone better
and you have another opportunity now to
be
the next iteration of yourself
that you can be
at a crossroads you know
the metaphor works because you make a
decision you go one direction or another
and there's an old blues
idea that you
meet the devil at the crossroads
i always wondered why that was i thought
it through it's a really compelling
idea you know it's a it's an image that
has a good narrative fit and it sticks
in your memory once you hear it why do
you meet the devil at the crossroads at
midnight maybe that's when you examine
your conscience
or it examines you
and then you might ask well why do you
meet the devil at the crossroads
and the answer is most fundamentally
because
when you come to a place in your life
where you have to make a choice
and i think this is actually true of
every choice we ever make but it's more
evident when the choice is more
weighty let's say
as the choices that lay themselves out
now in front of you are weighty you aim
up or down
and there is always an agent of
temptation at every choice point
enticing you
to aim down
and i thought a lot about what aiming
down means and so i'll
run through that for a bit
the spirit of temptation manifests
itself for example in the story of cain
and abel
and so cain falls prey to temptation and
god
bluntly
informs him
when he complains about his fate that
the temptation was freely chosen and
that he could have
done differently and better
and
cain becomes
this is in the aftermath of the improper
sacrifices that he makes
the sacrifices that he makes that are
not
everything they could be
they're not in the service of the
highest good
that are deceptive
and arrogant simultaneously because
when we make improper sacrifices we
believe in the deepest part of ourselves
that we've pulled one over god
and isis suggests that that's a
temptation you might want to avoid that
presumption
and then you might say well
if you're tempted to
aim down
you're tempted to make improper
sacrifices you're tempted to arrogantly
presume that you are going to get away
from it with it
that you're not going to be called on it
what are the pathways down that might
manifest themselves in front of you and
i think the the two stories that follow
the story of cain and abel
detail that
so after cain and abel comes the flood
and that's no accident the narrative
placement of those stories is definitely
no accidents it's unbelievably
sophisticated from a literary
perspective philosophical perspective
theological perspective
existential perspective one form of
temptation is
the nihilistic
chaos that's symbolically represented by
the flood right it's
the proliferation of sins
and sin is a word
both its greek and its hebrew derivation
are
related to archery
so the greek derivation i hope i haven't
got this wrong because i know there are
greek scholars in this audience so um
the the the word is derived from the
greek word hamartia which means to miss
the mark and it's an archery term it's
lovely i it's a lovely notion to know
that because to sin therefore means to
miss the target which implies that it
has something to do with aim or the lack
thereof
i love that i think it's so apt and the
derivation of the word sin from the
hebrew source actually relies on the
same imagery and so to sin is to aim
wrong or to miss the mark there's a
variety of ways you can miss the mark
right don't aim at all that's a good one
assume there is no such thing as aim
assume all aims are equal
well you sin you miss the mark
what can happen well one way is you can
descent into a kind of nihilistic
hopelessness and that's not
you can understand that you know you
meet people in life whose lives have
been so hard you you hear their stories
they've suffered so much and they're
bitter and they're hurt and they're
resentful and you think oh my god it's
no wonder you're bitter and resentful i
mean look what you've gone through
and but you also notice that their
bitterness and their resentment and
their hopelessness and their chaos and
their anxiety it's not helping
right it's worsening the problem it's
not making it better and i'm not saying
that people can always resist that
but i i i have certainly seen that it's
not helpful but i've also met other
people you know who have had stories
equally catastrophic sometimes more
catastrophic sometimes so catastrophic
you can't even believe that they
survived who are not embedded or made
residential by those experiences and who
continue to aim up and so that makes a
mockery of the of the of a kind of
casual determinism right is that you end
up chaotic nihilistic hopeless anxious
etc
merely as a consequence of the
unbearable tragedy of your life because
if that was the case then everyone who
had a series of unbearable tragedies
which by the way will be almost all of
us in one way or another at one time or
another would end up
in that
catastrophic chaos that
that once
that if manifested broadly enough in a
society produces a flood of
that ends everything and that's well
that's the story of noah in large part
and noah you know he's wise in his
generations was a lovely phrase because
it means for his time and place he was a
good man and that's that's a lens
through which history might well be
viewed you know we're very presumptuous
as moderns we look back and we think
well
you know this person who did all these
remarkable things said these things that
we now regard as inappropriate and
therefore can be dispensed with it's
like well
what makes you think that you're above
that criticism 100 years from now that
you know the best you can do is to be as
good as you can in your time and place
and if you can manage that well good for
you if you can transcend that well then
maybe you're some sort of saint and
you're probably not so aiming at just
the first is not such a bad upper aim
and so there's the chaos domain and i
would say
those of you who are graduating you want
to be tempted into that you know one of
the things i've thought a lot about in
relationship to faith you know we have
this idea it's not a good idea and it's
certainly a idea for which religious
people are often pilloried that faith
means the sacrifice of reason and the
willingness to believe things that are
patently not true
and when religious people debate
scientists they're often sort of hung
out to dry on exactly those presump
presuppositions their willingness to
accept on principle
propositions that seem on the face of
them impossible
i don't think that's what faith is at
all in in some fundamental sense
i think faith is a form of courage
you know if you're hurt by life and you
will be
it's understandable that you might react
in a nihilistic and hopeless fashion and
become anxious and depressed and cynical
and bitter and all of that
that's a bad pathway
and i think part of what helps you
through that is faith and and part of
that faith is that it's incumbent upon
you and actually in your best interest
and everyone else's
to maintain faith in the fundamental
goodness of existence including your own
despite the evidence to the contrary
right because you can draw conclusions
from suffering in two ways right one is
that you have a duty and perhaps the
capability to transcend the suffering
and still serve the good or you can
derive the conclusion that life is so
unbearable that it would be best
terminated which is the conclusion that
girth as mephistopheles derives for
example in faust he says well the world
is rife with suffering and it's so
unbearable that consciousness itself all
being should cease to exist that would
be better nothing is better than
something if something is rife with
suffering and you can derive that
conclusion and you'll be driven to it in
some
of the farther reaches of your life when
terrible things happen to you but i
would say
faith is the courage to not take that
path despite the evidence that that
might be
justified and so i think it is a form of
courage in the highest sense and i also
think it is a redeeming form of courage
one of the things i told my daughter who
was very very ill for a very long period
of time and in tremendous pain and
suffering the high probability of
continued slow painful inevitable
degeneration was
do not
let your illness do not take advantage
of your illness as an excuse
and i told her that when she was in
grade two you know it's no joke to tell
someone that because i knew she'd had
every reason to be embittered but i also
knew that if she was
in combination with her illness the two
things might be worse than fatal and you
know if you don't think there are things
that are worse than fatal you have not
suffered because there are things that
are much worse than fatal and there's
certainly not something you want to doom
your child to
so that's the
that's one temptation right that's the
temptation of a kind of faithless
hopelessness
and an army you might say
existential angst that you allow to
pervade yourself and i'm not saying you
won't have your reasons
because you will i'm saying that the
reasons don't justify the conclusion and
they certainly don't justify the
conclusion not self-evidently and they
don't justify the conclusion in any
simple deterministic sense you know i
met
met a woman once in my clinical practice
man this was something
she was as damaged a person as you could
hope to contemplate so she looked like a
street person she'd come to this
behavior therapy clinic that i worked in
as a student and
she was dressed like a street person you
know she had this old ratty
winter jacket on that was really dirty
and and she stooped over she wasn't very
tall to begin with she stooped over
hunched over and she approached everyone
like like this
which made people shy away from her
because it's an odd method of approach
but the reason she did that was she was
really so timid and so humble that it
was if as if anybody that she approached
had a light that was emanating them to
from them too unbearable for her to
behold so it wasn't so much an oddity
although it was as
an uh
well pretty natural humility and
i thought she had come to the behavior
clinic because she wanted help she was
an outpatient at a at a psychiatric
hospital that i worked at and
she couldn't communicate very well
partly from because of her shyness
partly because her first language was
french which maybe she could communicate
perfectly well in french but i doubt it
um she was not an intelligent person
technically speaking you know she she
was intellectually impaired and
probably in the bottom tenth percentile
of the population that's a pretty rough
place to exist cognitively you know
you're barely literate at that point and
and her mother was a
was very ill and was uh
bedridden and
her her mother had a boyfriend who was a
violent alcoholic schizophrenic who was
always haranguing her about satan and
like man she had a rough life it was she
just didn't have anything going for she
wasn't an attractive person physically
you know people shied away from her
she just was the downtrodden of the
earth you know in the realist sense and
that bloody woman you know she actually
came to that
behavior therapy clinic
she'd been an inpatient
and this was a rough place man because
it was a hospital after the
institutionalization and there were
tunnels connecting some of the wards to
other wards because it's so cold this
was in montreal so cold in the winter
they built a hospital on these tunnels
and i took my brother there one day and
it was like walking through dante's
inferno i mean if you were so
psychiatrically impaired that you
weren't released in the 1980s when the
institutionalization was maybe at its
peak you were so damaged that there was
just no possibility that you could
function in the outside world so the
people that were left were sort of the
the most
demolished of the most demolished and so
just walking through there for my
brother who had no experience in such
things was traumatizing you know and and
she had been in the inpatient ward
for some time and then was released and
she
wanted to
talk to the hospital administration
because she got out she got this dog
that she took care of and went for a
walk and she really liked this dog and
she took care of it you know and she
walked with it and she wanted to see if
she'd go find one of those on impatience
who was worse off than her
and take them for a walk every day with
her dog
you know
it's so funny you meet someone like that
and they just have nothing they have
nothing in the world that you would
recognize as any marker of success
or or status or ability or
they're outcast and tortured and and
then none of that nonetheless you know a
woman in that dismal state was able to
rise above her own catastrophe which was
like manifold and
find someone worse off to try to serve
you know
you don't need many experiences like
that to convince you that there's things
about the world that you truly don't
understand on the ethical front you know
so i would say
when you're at the crossroads and you're
counseled to despair
you know rise up in courage and see if
you can resist it it's better for you
and it's better for the people around
you
so
that's the flood man and so
the story that falls out of the tower of
babel
you know i was reading a wikipedia
article on the tower of babel the other
day
i'm always curious about how these
things are represented most publicly
right and wikipedia is a great way to do
that because it's collectively edited
and the interpretation was essentially
it was the description of how the
languages of the world arose
and i think i don't think that's what
that story is about at all except
peripherally i thought yeah you just
missed the point 100
i mean babel is babylon first so you
need to know that
and babylon is the state that's gone mad
and it's an it's a continual temptation
for human beings to build
complex organizations right
that get too high and so what does that
mean how about too many layers not local
enough not distributed enough right two
separate from the people that they serve
i think the eu did that i think that's
why the british left that's the tower of
babel in fact they used unbelievably
they used a famous painting of the tower
of babel as a representation of the eu
in some of their literature which i
think it was a painting by brugel but
i'm not sure of that but that was just
like okay i don't i just do not
understand how that happened at all um
in any case
this tower of babel it's it's also a
luciferian story you know lucifer is the
spirit of intellect the lightbringer
who
who's flown too high and
challenges god himself
and falls and in milton's story lucifer
is called on his pretension by god and
said you know if you because he is god's
highest angel gone most catastrophically
wrong so a symbol of intellect that in
combination with the notion that he's a
lightbringer it's a symbol of prideful
intellect and it is the prideful
intellect that raises itself against
what is most properly placed at the
highest place which is what god is
whatever that is
whatever it is it's not the intellect
that's a subordinate spirit and if it
isn't then it becomes aimed essentially
at something approximating hell and
perfectly capable of creating it and
then perfectly capable of ruling in it
and so god when god calls lucifer on his
rebellion he says if you but repent you
could be welcomed home and lucifer says
well i am the sort of spirit that even
if i once repented i would be instantly
tempted to merely repeat my my mistake
and he says as well i would rather rule
and held and serve in heaven it's like
hey man
there's a choice for you at the
crossroads
and so you know people have asked me for
example i'm very opposed to the idea
that the fundamental human motivation is
power which is pretty much what every
student is taught at every level of
their education in every educational
institution except a handful now across
your country fundamental motivation is
power there's no place for people of
good will to meet and have and engage in
constructive dialogue dialogues none of
that because our fundamental motivation
is nothing but the will to power and so
there is no place for people of good
will to meet there is no such thing as
dialogue it's all a mask a
rationalization a post-hoc
rationalization for
pretension and power it's such a dismal
philosophy it's so d you could not and i
i believe this technically you could not
formulate a more pathological philosophy
it obliterates your faith in society and
it eradicates the notion of the
individual it removes the notion of good
faith and good will and it makes
communication impossible it's like
that's a temptation to engage in that
sort of destruction as a consequence of
your intellectual pretensions let's say
and for all of you this is going to face
you too this pretension you know so
maybe you're not the hopeless type and
and and the temptation that assails you
at the crossroads isn't your
degeneration into a kind of faithless
nihilism maybe it's a
self-aggrandizement in some sense
instead and that you feel that now you
have the opportunity to serve your own
ambition
well we can take apart what that means
because i think it's worthwhile
psychopaths serve their own ambition
and they're the people who are most
truly motivated by power by the way if
you think about it clinically and
they're not very successful all uh
protestations to the contrary they never
rise above about three percent of any
general population and maybe it's a
better strategy to be a psycho
manipulative psychopath and to lay inert
on your in your bed in your mother's
bedroom when you're 40 but it's not an
optimal strategy
and so you can be get away with it being
a psychopath because you can mimic
competence and you can take advantage of
people who have learned to expect the
best from others and so you can
manipulate them but you produce nothing
on your own and one of the things that's
really interesting about psychopaths is
they don't learn from experience
which means not only do they betray
other people constantly
but they betray their own future selves
and there's really no difference between
your future self and someone else right
you know if you're going to act
ethically and this is a very good way of
thinking about acting ethically you act
in a way that works for you now
that works for you tomorrow that works
for you next week and next month the
next year and in five years and in ten
years and for you and your family and
your friends and your broader community
and
all of that simultaneously
and that's that's a place to find
purpose in your life to manage that
balancing act simultaneously and to
sacrifice your narrow
self-oriented pretensions ambition all
of that the celebration of your own
intellect the the construction of your
own empire for your own narrow purposes
part of the reason you shouldn't do that
even though it's tempting in some sense
especially if you have the ability is
because do you want to rule over hell
i mean and that's another interesting
question with regards to the question of
whether power is a valid motivation it's
like
okay well kim jong-un let's take him
he's a manifestation of a power player
you are you think it's better to be
leader of north korea than to be just an
ordinary peon there are you so sure it's
better to rule over hell than just to be
a servant in hell it's not obvious to me
that's not success by any stretch of the
imagination the most powerful devil
that's like the worst possible failure
and so you know you're called upon to to
take the lessons that you've been taught
in a university like this that the
teachers attempts to teach you to abide
by the eternal verities to sacrifice
your own narrow pretensions in the
highest sense to something that's truly
better not because you should in some
figure finger wagging sense but because
there is truly nothing better and
perhaps you don't have the wisdom to see
that because it's difficult to see it's
difficult to have a purview broad enough
to encompass those expanse of time in
community and see what pattern of
behavior is to be manifested in proper
service to balance all of that in some
musical manner
but that's definitely the
that's definitely the appropriate
pathway it's the best possible path of
action and anything you pursue that
isn't that is insufficient especially
for people of your ability and i would
also say and this is very much worth
thinking about too you know there is
this idea that your great country is
founded upon for example that
each individual is of divine worth
you know i made reference to this client
i had when i was a junior therapist and
so even the the most what would you say
ignored and and and alienated
marginalized let's say to use a word
that's been overused have something of
real value to bring into the world and
this is the case you're a particularized
creature as a son of god or a daughter
of god let's say you have something to
bring into the world that no one can
else no one else can bring in
and so if you fail in that duty then you
deprive the world of that
and maybe you shouldn't do that like
maybe everything's lesser if you do that
and you don't know how much lesser you
know because the world is also
constituted in a very strange way you
know dostoevsky said that we're not only
responsible for what we do but for what
everyone else does which is truly an
insane thing to say but also in some
sense fundamentally true you know i
don't know how it is that each of us can
bear the burden of the world on our
shoulders singularly because
i can't really comprehend how things can
be structured in that manner but i do
believe nonetheless that it is the case
and so that if you forswear your
responsibility to the highest good then
you tear something out of the fabric of
being that
that is of inestimable value and i do
believe you will pay for that if you do
it and i would suggest that you don't
pay that price because it will not be
pleasant that's definitely hell
and if you don't think hell is real you
haven't thought about it enough
it isn't a matter of other people
believing foolish things it's a matter
of you being so naive and so well
protected that you have no idea how the
world is constituted
and so
and so that's well that's the
temptations let's say chaos and nihilism
and hopelessness or intellectual
pretension and the desire for
self-aggrandizement and narrow power
don't do that it's not helpful it won't
do you any good and it it's beneath you
you know it's beneath you to do that and
you and you that will manifest itself in
your life that that that that
subordination of what's highest in you
to those lesser gods let's say
that'll manifest itself in the torments
of your own conscience and no one
escapes from that you know and so
don't do that
don't make that choice at the crossroads
and then we might say practically
speaking because i'm a behavioral
psychologist you know i like to be
practical well that's what you shouldn't
do
what should you do practically well
we could walk through that you know a
little bit practically
i'll have lots of
clients and students who were chaotic in
their orientation life they didn't know
what to do and they didn't know what to
do about not knowing what to do it's
like i don't know what to do with my
life and i don't know what to do about
my ignorance and my act my reaction to
that in some sense wasn't exactly the
reaction of a a clinician because
not a typical clinician because typical
clinicians are liberal protestant in
their fundamental orientation and they
tend to think of psychological
development as something like
self-actualization right it's really a
self-development
process but i i that wasn't my my
observation partly
influenced by the developmental
psychologist sean piaget i had a more
communitarian view of human development
than that and my observation was that
most people find the sa the cardinal
meanings in their life not
as a consequence of the development of
their self whatever that is but in
service to other people in in the
adoption of responsibility
you know because you're told be
responsible and it's a finger wagging
thing again you know that if you were a
good person you'd be responsible you do
your duty but no one ever says
well because that's where you find the
abiding meaning in your life and you
need that meaning to sustain you through
suffering and that's definitely the case
you know i was very ill for a number of
years and a lot of what got me through
that
wasn't my own special
nature let's say but the support of my
family and the support of my friends and
the support of the broader community
made a huge difference not only
psychologically because i knew people
were supporting me but also practically
you build yourself a community
you sacrifice yourself in the service of
other people not so much because you
should although you should but because
that is where meaning is to be found and
you need a deep meaning to sustain you
through tragedy that's the ark
and you find that deep meaning and you
know there's a notion that it's better
to give to receive than to receive and
it sounds like a hallmark greeting card
in some sense and and people are cynical
about that too yeah you say that because
you should be good and think that and
but if you watch yourself you'll see
that it's true because one of the things
that's been really
uh pronounced element in my life is that
you know people thank me from time to
time from for things that i've done or
said and there isn't a better
experience than that you know that
you've put something out that's actually
a manifestation of what you truly
believe and the consequence of that is
part of the redemptive process for
someone else there is nothing that's
better than that zero nothing in fact i
don't think there's anything that's even
in the same conceptual universe of that
in terms of its intrinsically rewarding
properties there's nothing better than
to have people as perhaps particularly
people you've never met tell you that
what you have been doing has had a
salutary effect on their lives that's
and so that's a hell of a fine thing to
aim for
and why not import you know because you
could do it
if you put i don't i wouldn't even say
necessarily that you put other people
first because i think that's a mistake
but i do think it's the case that you
treat other people
in the manner that you would wish to be
treated if you were treating yourself
properly and that's also a sophisticated
thing right to learn to treat yourself
properly because that doesn't mean you
get to fulfill every momentary whim
because that's what you do when you're
two and two-year-olds can't live without
their parents
you know you have to be wise enough to
govern your current behavior in light of
the future and that's really what it
means to be an adult it's what it means
to forestall gratification
and to and to attain the responsibility
of an adult and the reason that you
should do that because you should is
because it's actually better you know in
all ways it's it's an it's a panacea for
suffering to adopt that responsibility
and so i would tell my clients and
students as well it's like well let's
just take a look at where other people
find meaning
you know and and we'll see how your life
matches with that do you have an
intimate relationship
yes or no the right answer is yes now
maybe not for you and maybe you don't
right now and maybe you have your
reasons not to because you're a singular
person in that regard but probably not
because that's like a third of life and
so if you don't have that
that might be one of the reasons you're
not doing so well and the fact that you
don't have it might be an indication
that you're not oriented in the proper
direction
i can give you an example that i had
many people questioned me when i was
just on tour this is a question that
came up quite rapidly often um in the q
and a sessions
how do i find the right person when i'm
dating how do i find the person who's
right for me when i'm dating and i got
that or on the internet uh
i got the question like three times in a
row and i thought because i always think
this what about that question
what's wrong with that question
something wrong with that question
how about
how do i conduct myself so that i am the
best possible partner
now that's a whole different right
that's a whole different conceptual
universe and virtually no one ever asked
that question and i would say well if
you want an answer to the first question
which is how do i find the person who's
right for me you actually start by
asking the second question which is what
can i bring to the table for someone
else and if you're really good at
bringing something to the table for
someone else hey man people might be
lining up to be your partner and if
they're not then you might think well
maybe i'm just not bringing the right
thing to the table
and that's worth thinking especially if
you're desperate you're lost and you're
alone it's like hmm maybe i got this
wrong and i you know i usually sort of
top that with the suggestion that even
if you did find the person who was
perfect for you and they're that perfect
what makes you think they wouldn't take
one look at you and run screaming away
and they likely would if they were that
perfect because you know really are you
that much of a catch
and if you think you are you know that
might be part of the problem um
so so look so that's one right intimate
relationship so i would say to you at
the crossroads develop a vision for your
relationship
you know there's a gospel saying which
is of course impossible to comprehend or
believe knock on the door will open ask
and you will receive seek and you will
find and people think well no way the
world's not constituted like that it's
like it goes back to the idea of aim
if you don't aim at it you're not going
to hit it
and you know it might also go back to a
question about what do you mean by ask
and what do you mean by want because it
isn't just some casual request you know
you're praying to god i wish you know i
wish i could find my wallet or something
like that as if he's the casual grantor
of magical wishes like like like a fairy
with a magic wand you know it's not that
asking means asking means something like
this i am willing to give up everything
that i'm doing wrong
so that i can put things right if i
could know what right was
and that's a non you're on your knees
when you say that man and maybe if
you're on your knees you get the answer
and so that's worth thinking about so
you know if you knocked and you wanted
to walk through and you asked and you
wanted to learn
you know and you sought because you
wanted to find maybe you would
receive
and
be answered and
find
but not without aim
and so i might say well look if you
could have the relationship you wanted
you get to have the relationship you
want and need
but you have to know what it is
and so then you need a vision of that
it's like an and a developed vision you
know no i need to find the person right
for me it's like what do you mean by
that
you know how about how are you going to
treat your partner when they come home
from work how about something that
concrete or how would you like to be
treated when you come home from work
or what sort of partner do you want in
relationship to their attitude towards
children you have to make it real you
know like it's the story of your own
life which by the way it is
and then maybe you find it because at
least once you've developed the vision
if it manifests itself you'll recognize
it that's something
so then you need an intimate
relationship well
why don't you set your family right
you know you need siblings maybe you
don't have them set your relationship
with your parents right fix your
relationship with your father with your
mother with your siblings
the same thing and what sort of
relationship do you have want to have
with your children you know if you could
have what you wanted i had a very good
relationship with my children
my daughter as i said was very ill so
that made things complicated but i had a
great relationship and still do with my
son it's it's one of the lights of our
life
and we concentrated on making that
relationship pristine you know both of
us and my wife as well
and so imagine well i want my son to
love me i want my son to respect me and
vice versa i want a child who can make
mature decisions i want someone i can
rely on i want someone who other people
gravitate towards
because i can have what i want if i'm
willing to make the proper sacrifices
and so that's that's a good thing could
you set your family straight
well you need a job or a career and so
what can you offer and what can you
bring the world in that regard and not
and then i would say well if you're
thinking about career success in this
tower of babel manner then that's a
temptation but you might think well how
much could good could i do if i had the
opportunity in the shortest possible
period of time if i went all in
and then that's there's a name man
there's a name and then you might think
well what would that look like you know
if i was a light to my community if i
was a light to the people i work with
who would i be if i was like that
and and then you can conceptualize that
and you can see when you deviate from it
and why couldn't you
correct for the deviations and move
towards that
and then you might say well you are
going to make productive use of your
time outside of work productive and
generous use of your time productive
generous and meaningful use of your time
how about that
you're going to control your
your susceptibility to temptation
regulate your alcohol and drug use
because alcoholism takes out lots of
people regulate your sexual temptation
can control yourself for some reason
that's worth controlling yourself for
you know because there's something to
being civil right there's at least the
momentary pleasure it's not nothing and
you're not going to sacrifice that if
you have any sense unless you sacrifice
it to something clearly better you know
most this is classic clinical finding
with regards to alcoholics the only
cure we know for alcoholism is religious
transformation
even the hardcore secular researchers
know that they don't know why but they
know that's the case and part of the
reason for that is that if you're an
alcoholic you really like alcohol
it's an end it's an anti-anxiety agent
of potency
and it's a stimulant it's a great drug
and so once you have a great drug a
great spirit let's say you need
something better to replace it with
and maybe you can find something better
it appears that way because people do
and then they stop drinking
and so
and then there's service civic service
to your community you know i've been
thinking about church lately people have
abandoned the churches and vice versa in
many ways
and people think you know i can't
believe what the church teaches it's
like first of all who cares what you
believe like who are you anyways
right well really it's like i'm 16 i
don't like what the church teaches yeah
that's who you are you're the judge of
the church and you're 16. and that's
like that's commonplace i know it's
funny but it's not because that's a
common place so that was certainly me at
16. who could believe that you know i'm
above that it's like really here's this
15 year old juvenile delinquent from
northern alberta and it's like
who cares about
saint augustine anyways you know what
did he know
so
yeah so civic duty well i'm not going to
go into politics because it's a snake
pit you know or maybe you're cynical
about social institutions it's like well
go fix them
right you know they'll give you
something to do if they're so wrecked
great
well
it's an opportunity
you see something broken
fix it
and then you're the person who fixes it
like good for you man it's like you got
something to do really and then people
think hey you're the guy that fixed that
maybe you could fix this
and this and this and this and then you
fix things and your life just expands
you know
i guess i'll tell you too something
about telling the truth so one thing i
did a 1985
82
83
82
i i swore that i would stop lying
i said i'm going to try not to say
anything i know to be untrue you know
that doesn't mean i swore to tell the
truth because truth that's hard but you
can consciously stop
lying when you know you're lying
you can stop doing that
and that has been revolutionary for me
and and one of the things i've really
realized in recent years and this is
very much worth knowing is that
many times when people speak to each
other
they have an agenda in mind you know
you want something from someone maybe
you want a job and you want to craft
your image
to get the job right so you say what you
need to say to get what you think you
need the problem with that is what do
you know about what you need you're so
accurate about that are you
and you think you know what you need
exactly and so you're going to
falsify your utterances to bring about
the desired end and you're going to use
the other person as a target of your
manipulation
well that's like you write an essay
because that's what the professor wants
to hear it's like you don't do that
because you don't falsify your words
because hypothetically they're divine
and the whole stability of the state
rests on them hypothetically and maybe
really too
and so you don't do that
and so instead you strive to tell the
truth and maybe that's an aim too
and then it's an adventure because i'll
tell you one thing if you tell the truth
you have no idea what's going to happen
to you
because you have to let go of that it's
like i'm going to say what i think and
then what i'm going to assume faith i'm
going to assume that whatever happens if
i am telling the truth
is the best thing that could happen
because the truth brings about what is
best and even if it looks hard for me
because it might be you know because
people take the easy way out often when
they lie
even if it looks bad for me
that doesn't mean it's bad it just means
i don't see the whole
i don't see the whole picture and you
know if you believe that the truth will
set you free and that there is such a
thing as the truth and that the truth is
redemptive then you're pretty much stuck
with that conclusion but one of the
remarkable things about that and this
really is worth knowing is that if you
do that you will have your adventure
right the that's the abrahamic adventure
you know the call from god that
justifies your life because of the
excitement of what you're doing and the
truth does that and then if it's the
truth man it's your adventure because
what bloody adventure are you having if
you tell someone else's story
it's not yours
and maybe if it's not yours it's not
good enough for you and then you suffer
and then you're bitter and then you're
cruel and then you're resentful
that's not good or you get arrogant
so
so you break up your life you know into
practicalities your career your
education
your intimate relationship your marriage
your friendship hopefully your intimate
relationship and your marriage are the
same thing
your use of time outside work your civic
duty you know when you develop an image
for yourself a vision for yourself on
all those fronts and assume that you can
have with the proper sacrifices what you
need and want and then i'll say
something interesting about that because
that's the pursuit of goods in a
practical way right and
what's valuable in a practical way in an
implementable way and you pick those
pathways and you dedicate yourself to
their optimization along any of those
axes and then you learn to optimize a
name
and then you see once you've learned to
optimize a name across a set of goods
you start to aim at what is what unites
those goods
because that's what makes goods good
it's whatever is common across a set of
goods that's the highest good or a
higher good and so by practicing any
good in any rigorous sense and making
the proper sacrifices in that direction
you simultaneously learn to approach the
good that is the sum
or the essence of all those
proximal goods and i would say that the
the essential
insistence in christianity is that the
good that unites all those goods is the
same good that's reflected in the image
of christ which is an image of
acceptance of the suffering of life and
the necessity of serving the lowest as
the highest calling
and that's something and it might be
true
like really actually 100 percent true
more true than anything else and i
actually think it is partly because the
freest societies that we have that the
world has ever known the more successful
societies are predicated on precisely
that idea
as an unshakable foundation a
self-evident truth in the case of your
country and so it might be true and if
it is true and if that is real then why
in the world would you ever attempt to
do anything else
and it's kind of earth-shattering in
some sense to take this with real
seriousness you know it's all very
frightening if you're not afraid by of
that of that vision you know and what it
implies for you
and your soul then you didn't understand
it but it's also an unbelievably
what would you say endlessly promising
vision of what your life could be
and you know you might think well i need
a life so rich that i can justify its
suffering
and that's really asking for something
because there's no shortage of suffering
in life and it's
no one thinks their own suffering isn't
real
and maybe there's a possibility that
there's some aim that's so high that
that the attempt
that the attempt alone to move in that
direction is of sufficient value to
act as a panacea for the suffering and
so you could say at the end of your life
oh my god that was so hard
it was worth it
and so that's the choice you make at the
crossroads
if you have any sense
oh
thank you
[Applause]
you